hallo zusammen schön guten Abend wir
sind live mit ZDF heute live und wollen
heute Abend über die aktuelle Lage im
Iran sprechen da soll die Sittenpolizei
abgeschafft worden sein angeblich und
jetzt stellt sich eben die Frage ist das
ein Etappen Sieg der Protestbewegung
oder ist das Propaganda das Regimes und
stimmt es überhaupt Gerät das molaregime
so langsam in Panik darüber wollen wir
heute abend reden mit spannenden Gästen
die uns die Situation erklären und
einordnen werden zum einen mit unserem
Korrespondenten für Iran Jörg Brase und
außerdem gleich mit der
Menschenrechtsaktivistin die sind Türkei
und der Journalistin Gilda seibi und Sie
können sehr gerne Fragen und Kommentare
schicken wir wollen so viel wie geht an
unsere Gäste weitergeben am besten
einfach in die Chats posten oder an die
E-Mail-Adresse schicken die jetzt
eingeblendet ist bevor wir ins Gespräch
gehen geben uns Jörg Brase und Franziska
von tiesenhausen einen kurzen Überblick
darüber was aktuell in Iran passiert
sie kommen in kleinen Bussen
uniformierte Frauen im Tschador nehmen
die mit die sich nicht genau an die
Kleidervorschriften halten
Irans Sittenpolizei setzt die
kopftuchregeln oft mit brutaler Härte
durch
seit den 80er Jahren gibt es strenge
Vorschriften für Frauen seit 2005 sogar
eine offizielle Einheit die zuletzt dem
Innenministerium unterstellt war die
Moralwächter sollen Frauen im richtigen
Tragen des hijob unterweisen seit dem
Tod von Marsa Amini die nach
Misshandlungen durch die Sittenpolizei
starb steht die Truppe noch massiver in
der Kritik am Wochenende soll sich Irans
Generalstaatsanwalt indirekt zur
Auflösung der Einheit geäußert haben
eine offizielle Bestätigung des
Innenministeriums gibt es nicht laut
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft soll auch über
eine Reform der Kopftuch Regeln
diskutiert werden
meinte irans Präsident raisi genau das
auf einer Pressekonferenz am Samstag in
Teheran die iranische Verfassung sei gut
und richtig meinte er aber
die Methoden um unsere Gesetze
umzusetzen können überprüft werden nicht
aber die Werte die den Gesetzen zugrunde
liegen die Methoden können wir ändern
nicht aber die Werte
Äußerungen die Fragen aufwerfen ist das
Regime nach wochenlangen Protesten
wirklich bereit Zugeständnisse zu machen
oder handelt es sich nur um ein
Ablenkungsmanöver
und wir erreichen unseren Iran
Korrespondenten Jörg Brase in Istanbul
hallo ja guten Abend
Jörg Sittenpolizei abgeschafft ja nein
vielleicht was ist da gerade los in Iran
also ich denke was wir da jetzt im
Moment sehen das ist auch ein Kampf um
die Informationshoheit diese Meldung war
sehr
missverständlich
verbreitet worden von der staatlichen
Nachrichtenagentur ist zeigte sich dann
auch heute eigentlich immer mehr je mehr
hat man erfährt zu den Umständen dieses
Interviews dass er er hat gefragt wurde
auf der einer Pressekonferenz dazu eine
Antwort gab und die konnte man jetzt so
oder so interpretieren die staatliche
Nachrichtenagentur hat es so übersetzt
dass man daraus schließen muss dass sie
sich ein Polizei geschlossen wurde oder
zugemacht wurde im Grunde aber
sagte er nichts anderes als dass es
eigentlich nicht die nicht das
Justizsystem ist dass wir die
moralpolizei zuständig ist sondern
andere Institutionen die die Polizei
dann auch schließen könnten genauso wie
eröffnet hatten also mehr oder weniger
hat er gesagt dass er eigentlich nichts
damit zu tun hat aber das wurde dann
entsprechend so kommuniziert
jetzt muss man natürlich sehen ich
glaube persönlich nicht also dass ich da
und wie viele andere auch glaube ich
nicht dass ich irgendetwas geändert hat
ich glaube auch nicht dass sie hinten
Polizei abgeschafft wurde ich glaube
auch nicht dass ich an den Regeln etwas
ändern wird ich halte das eher für eine
Nebelkerze die geworfen wurde am Tag
bevor die Opposition eben zu
landesweiten Protesten aufgerufen hatte
man versucht da offensichtlich einen
Teil zu treiben in die
Oppositionsbewegung hinein Leuten zu
suggerieren dass man bereit ist
Konzession zu machen dass man bereit ist
Reformen durchzusetzen vielleicht die
Kopftuch Regeln etwas zu liberalisieren
etwas zu lockern aber es gibt nichts was
darauf Hinweis dass das tatsächlich
passiert im Gegenteil also es wurden ja
auch Leute bestraft die z.B in einer
Bank
oder in einem Einkaufszentrum Frauen
bedient haben die keinen Kopftuch trugen
sobald der Staat Zugriff hat auf diese
Institution tut er das auch und sowohl
der Geschäftsführer dieses
Einkaufszentrums als auch der Direktor
hier in der Bank es wurden dann
hinterher sagen sioniert und der Justiz
der von gestern auch der
Generalstaatsanwalt der gestern auch
noch mal gesagt dass letztlich die
Justiz auf weiterhin dafür zuständig
sein wird die islamischen
Kleidervorschriften zu kontrollieren und
auch durchzusetzen das heißt du hast
gerade gesagt die Sittenpolizei und da
steht dem iranischen Innenministerium
gesprochen hat aber ja gestern der
Generalstaatsanwälte auch wieder eine
komplett andere Baustelle
was würdest du sagen du hast eben gesagt
das wird gezielt gemacht Wetter gezielt
Verwirrung gestiftet oder könnte es auch
einfach sein dass es wirklich nicht
besonders optimal kommuniziert war
dass ich da jemand geäußert hat der
dafür eigentlich gar nicht
gedacht war
also wir stellen uns die Frage auf war
das jetzt eine gezielte
desinformations-kampagne mit dem mit dem
Ziel eben die
Opposition zu spalten Leute Leuten
Signale zu geben dass man Reformen will
ich oder oder auch diskussionsfähig ist
oder was es einfach nur eine
Fehlkommunikation so richtig an
Fehlkommunikation will man da eigentlich
nicht glauben es gibt allerdings auch
heute direkt wieder Signale die in die
andere Richtung gehen also von Seiten
revolutionsgarten wurde gesagt dass man
auf jeden Fall gegen die Protestierenden
gegen die Demonstrationen die er jetzt
für
drei Tage heute bis Mittwoch angekündigt
waren dass man da sehr Arsch gegen
vorgehen will man hat auch verlangt dass
Urteile oder Gerichtsverfahren gegen
festgenommene Demonstranten und
Demonstranten auch zügig jetzt
durchgeführt werden auch Irans oberster
Führer Allee hat hat ebenfalls gesagt
dass man unterscheidet zwischen zwischen
friedlichen Demonstranten und zwischen
Aufrührern die mit aller Härte verfolgt
und gestraft werden müssen ist deutet
eigentlich nichts darauf hin dass das
Regime in irgendeiner Form wirklich
Kompromiss willig ist sondern auf jeden
Fall versuchen wird diese Demonstration
zu beenden aber ich glaube das was man
auch dazu sagen muss sie wissen schon um
das um das Protestpotenzial was was da
gibt im Land und insofern gibt es da
auch durchaus Diskussionen wie man da
jetzt vorgehen soll gegen diese
Demonstration gegen die Demonstranten
und Demonstranten und man weiß auch dass
je nachdem was da jetzt für Maßnahmen
ergriffen werden das auch ins Gegenteil
umschlagen kann und insofern wird da
sicherlich diskutiert kontrovers
diskutiert mit welchen Methoden man
jetzt vorgehen soll vielleicht noch kurz
zum Schluss die Aktivisten und
Aktivistin haben jetzt für drei Tage
lang zu einem Generalstreik aufgerufen
was kann dieser Streik der
Freiheitsbewegung bringen
also wir müssen jetzt mal schauen wie
groß dieser Streik ist wir haben ja
heute Bilder gesehen aus verschiedenen
Städten wo
Geschäftsleute dem Aufruf nachgekommen
sind ihre Geschäfte geschlossen zu
halten es ist ein wirtschaftsstreik den
man jetzt versucht zu organisieren es
gibt auch im Internet Aufrufe keine
Produkte zu kaufen oder nicht weil mit
Firmen zusammen zu arbeiten die dem
System die den revolutionsgarten nahe
stehen also man versucht da zivilen
Widerstand zu leisten jetzt auch über
über wirtschaftliche Maßnahmen die man
versucht über das Internet zu
organisieren insofern ja also diese
diese drei Tage das kann natürlich schon
eine eine Wirkung erzielen je nachdem
wie viel Leute mitmachen es gibt auch
viele die sich im Moment noch nicht
trauen auf die Straße zu gehen eben aus
Angst vor
Repressionen der Sicherheitsbehörden die
aber dann wenn es um solche Maßnahmen
geht er bereit sind da auch mit zu
machen und insofern muss man jetzt mal
sehen wie erfolgreich diese drei Tage
sind die ja dann münden am Mittwoch in
den Tag der Studenten an denen dann
Präsident Reis die dann auch an der
Teheraner Universität sprechen will und
wir davon ausgehen eigentlich dass man
versucht diese Veranstaltungen zu stören
und deshalb müssen wir jetzt mal
abwarten wie sich die die nächsten zwei
Tage sind es ja jetzt nur noch wie die
sich gestalten werden
ich danke dir sehr für diese
Informationen mach's gut tschüss
ja jetzt haben wir tschüss jetzt haben
wir einen guten Überblick wie die
aktuelle Situation im Iran ist und wir
sehen auch gerade im Chat da gibt es
viel Unterstützung zum Beispiel schreibt
sound of nality ich kann dem iranischen
Volk nur wünschen dass sie es schaffen
sich von diesem Joch zu befreien aber es
gibt auch so ein bisschen wenig Hoffnung
im Moment so schreibt
Katrin auf Facebook ich glaube nur dass
ich dort höchstens etwas verlagern wird
eventuell wird das Kind in
Anführungszeichen auch nur umgetauft
dann wird es nicht schaffen wollen sehr
lange etablierte Gedanken von jetzt auf
gleich komplett zu verändern wir wollen
die Situation weiter analysieren und
zwar mit der
Menschenrechtsaktivistin und Autoren
designal und der Journalistin Gilda
seibi dich jetzt ganz herzlich begrüße
guten Abend
ich würde gerne mit ihnen beginnen und
auf meine Eingangsfrage des Streams
zurückkommen eine angebliche Auflösung
dieser Sittenpolizei ist das Fake News
oder tatsächlich ein Fortschritt wie
sehen Sie das ja das ist fake News aber
da können wir ganz deutlich sein das ist
Sittenpolizei Lügerei und das ist eine
Nachricht ganz konkret an den Westen
sozusagen gerichtet und das bedauerliche
daran ist dass der Westen darauf
hineinfällt also dass die New York Times
z.B dreimal seinen Beitrag korrigieren
musste zeigt eigentlich wie ohnmächtig
wir sind wenn so ein Unrechtsregime
jetzt eben auch diese Informationsflut
sich zu eigen macht und natürlich auch
die newstrollen möchte und das zeigt
eigentlich auch wie sehr dieses Müller
Regime unter Druck steht und das hat
natürlich auch mit dem Generalstreik zu
tun und das Ziel dieses Regimes ist die
Spaltung also auch der eigenen
Zivilbevölkerung diese Solidarität die
beispielsweise heute entstanden ist
durch den
Generalstreik wo beispielsweise auch
Vermieter Miete erlassen haben wo in
über 40 Städten die Läden sozusagen
geschlossen waren wo über 90 Prozent der
Menschen auch teilgenommen haben und das
ist nicht nur von Aktivisten initiiert
hier geht es um Wirtschaft hier geht es
um die Basare hier geht es um die
Erdölindustrie also es sind sehr viele
gemeinsam das verbindet ja diese Iran
Revolution von Kurdistan das ist Teheran
und insofern müssen wir uns vielleicht
auch hinterfragen welche News wir
zulassen und welche wir unterdrücken und
das ist eine Taktik zu zerstören und das
Ziel vom Regime ist Spaltung und dazu
gehört eben auch die Fake News mit
dieser sogenannten Sittenpolizei vor
allem was soll das bedeuten die
revolutionsladen sind immer noch da es
wird immer noch geworden die
Todesurteile sollen immer noch
vollstreckt werden immer noch sitzen
18000 Menschen in den Gefängnissen und
wir können nur appellieren gemeinsam ich
glaube das spreche auch im Namen von
meiner Kollege doch lieber den Fokus zu
lenken 18.000 Inhaftierten und über das
zu sprechen was mit ihnen ist und was
das für Geschichten und Gesichter sind
als auch diese Fake News dieses Regimes
hinein zu fallen
Frau sahibi ich würde sie gerne Fragen
trotzdem angenommen es wäre so gewesen
was würde das der Bewegung überhaupt
bringen denn wie Frau Türkei
gerade sagte entschuldigung es ist ja
natürlich so dass es die
revolutionsgarten noch gibt den
berüchtigten Geheimdienst also ganz ganz
viele andere repressive Instrumente
genauso man muss wirklich erstmal sagen
dass es Desinformation war die leider
sehr viele große Medien Deutschland
heute geteilt haben die haben wir
überall gesehen und das ist nicht gut
weil das pure Desinformation war das
heißt die Sittenpolizei ist nicht
abgeschafft worden und ich gehe auch
hier Brothers gesagt auch nicht davon
aus dass es passiert
es die Sittenpolizei ist eins von vielen
Instrumenten mit dem mit denen dieses
Regime seine Unterdrückung durchführt
diese Polizisten Beitrag auch gesagt
besteht seit 2005 seit 1979 hat dieses
Regime sehr erfolgreich auch ohne diese
Polizei Frauen unterdrückt und getötet
und misshandelt von daher braucht dieses
System die Sittenpolizei nicht und für
die Menschen im Iran also ich hatte die
Nachricht sofort eine Freundin geschickt
und die hat auch nur gesagt also das ist
alles Lügerei jeder einzelne von ihnen
ist diese Polizei und das passt ja auch
zu dem was Präsident wer sie gesagt hat
unsere Werte bleiben und Werte ist ein
sehr komisches Wort für das was er meint
Werte heißt in der Islamischen Republik
der Revolution des Landes der Revolution
heißt
Frauenverachtung Unterdrückung von
Menschenrechten
Menschenrechtsverletzungen Hinrichtung
von Minderjährigen das sind alles die
Werte dieser Republik und die werden
durchgesetzt und umgesetzt auch ganz
wunderbar ohne diese Polizei
Frau TK halt trotzdem würden Sie sagen
dass mittlerweile eine gewisse
Nervosität in der Führung spürbar ist
Russisch salmani schreibt auf YouTube
eine Hand weiß nicht was die andere tut
sie geraten in Panik
absolut das ist der 82 Tag der Iran
Revolution die Proteste gehen weiter es
hört nicht auf trotz aller druckkulissen
trotz der Tatsache dass insbesondere in
Saarland fast jeden Freitag insbesondere
aber eben auch in den chronischen
Provinzen so brutal zugeschlagen wird
werden Sie in der Lage nicht mehr und
das zeigen eben auch diese Nachrichten
auch völlig verschiedenen Ebenen und
tatsächlich eben auch die Erkenntnis
darüber dass dieser dieser Krieg gegen
das eigene Volk äh was sozusagen dieses
Regime führt zu bezeichnet ist es
zumindest wir müssen da aufpassen dass
eben jeder nicht auf falsche negative
hineinfallen dass wir das als
bürgerliche Zustände beschreiben aber es
ist in der Tat ein Krieg gegen die
eigene Zwiebel Bevölkerung und der wird
natürlich auch medial geführt und das
merkt man daran dass anders gesprochen
wird als gehandelt wird beispielsweise
also heute gab es ja auch Festnahmen von
Frauen
dürfen uns da nichts vormachen wir
dürfen uns auch keine Illusion machen
dass dieses faschistisch klerikale
System auch auf der Unterdrückung der
Frau gebaut ist und dazu gehört
natürlich auch das Kopftuch wenn das
Kopftuch fällt fällt das Regime und das
kann sich dieses Regime gar nicht
erlauben da überhaupt verbale
Zugeständnisse zu machen und dann wieder
zurückzugehen das ist etwas was die
Bevölkerung seit 43 Jahren kennt und
deswegen ist es so wichtig wer in diesem
Kontext eben auch zu Wort kommt und dass
man eben auch mit den Menschen vor Ort
so weit es möglich ist auch darüber
spricht aber wenn ich das mal so
wiedergeben darf sagen meine Quellen mir
insbesondere aus dem Westen des Irans
das trotz aller Toten und und verletzen
und der unsicheren Stimmung auch eine
Aufbruchstimmung da ist und ein großer
Stolz darüber beispielsweise dass dieser
Stille Protest trotzdem so laut und so
wirklich ist und es gibt sehr viele
Anzeichen dafür dass dieses Regime unter
Druck steht das hat auch was damit zu
tun dass sie sich gezwungen fühlen sich
überhaupt zu äußern also sie merken dass
sie der Situation nicht her werden und
deswegen wird ja die Gelegenheit
ergriffen Fake News zu produzieren die
Bevölkerung aufeinander aufzuhetzen aber
egal was sie tun ist gelingt nicht sie
wollen wollen und Solidarität sozusagen
säen und Stiften und es passiert eben
genau das Gegenteil die nächsten Tage
werden hier noch mal sehr interessant
sehr entscheidend und auch aus den
unterschiedlichen Bereichen ist immer
wieder die Frage wie geht es in den
anderen Städten weiter und deswegen darf
man diesen Generalstreik in drei tägigen
das muss man sich mal vergegenwärtigen
dass die Menschen sich das immer noch
Frauen immer noch Frauen während
Menschen erhängt werden man kann es
nicht anders sagen wenn das keine
Revolution ist was dann und natürlich
steht das Regie dementsprechend auch
unter Druck wenn noch mal man kann sich
auch genug sagen die Menschen wollen
keine Reform die wollen dass dieses
regimefeld und wollen ihre eigene
Freiheit und sie wissen dass das mit
diesem Regime nicht mehr möglich ist und
die lassen sich da auch nichts mehr
vormachen deswegen sollten wir im Westen
da haben sie ein ganz wichtigen Punkt
angesprochen dass man ja auch immer
sehen muss dass protestieren auf der
Straße in Iran momentan eine
lebensgefährliche Angelegenheit ist und
viele bleiben zu Hause
protestieren nicht mit haben aber die
hundertprozentige Unterstützung für
diese Bewegung also die Unterstützung
ist noch sehr viel breiter Frau sahibi
es gibt in einer iranischen
Hackergruppe der ist es gelungen eine
Tonbandaufnahme zu veröffentlichen die
sehen wir hier auf Youtube kann sich
mittlerweile vielleicht kann man das
kurz zeigen genau kann sich mittlerweile
jeder anschauen ja auf jeden Fall wird
da doch deutlich dass ich wirklich Rang
hohe Regime Vertreter Sorgen über die
Lage machen inwiefern da alles noch
unter ihrer Kontrolle ist
absolut also die das ist auch ganz
interessant was für Strategien Sie sich
überlegen um dagegen vorzugehen und da
ist nämlich ganz zentral weil das jetzt
auch Thema war die Media Strategie die
mediale Strategie also die diskutieren
zum Beispiel relativ lang darüber wie
man denn jetzt von Regime Seite diese
Proteste nennen soll man soll sie nicht
Proteste nennen
das Framing des wording jetzt haben sie
sich auch sowas wie schwarze Mission
eingestellt auch also Krawalle auch
schwarz Mission und man soll immer davon
sprechen dass diese Mission diese dunkle
schwarze Mission der Menschen beendet
sei dass die Krawalle beendet sein man
soll immer nur in der Vergangenheit
davon sprechen das ist eine der Sachen
dann haben Sie zum Beispiel sich
überlegt wie sie dagegen vorgehen können
dass in den Städten eben immer mehr
Frauen sind wir haben die Bilder vorhin
gesehen die ohne Kopftuch herumlaufen es
sind sehr viele viele Orte im ganzen
Land laufen die Frauen inzwischen ohne
Kopftuch herum und da haben sie überlegt
wie sie dagegen vorgehen und dann haben
sie sich über sehr gut wie wäre es denn
wenn wir einfach Frauen mit schador
einfach in den Städten platzieren also
Tschador ist dieses meist schwarze
ganzkörpergewandt und das ist so abstrus
aber so denken Sie sie denken wirklich
das Bild und daran sieht man wieder wie
wichtig ihm das Bild ist das nach außen
scheint das auch in den besten scheint
besonders in den Westen dass man dort
diese verschleierten Frauen sieht damit
im Westen nicht gedacht wird dass diese
Protestbewegung diese Revolution
irgendwie funktioniert und deswegen man
sieht anhand dessen auch wie sehr sie
doch in die Enge getrieben sind und
übrigens regen sie sich auch darüber auf
wie viel Frauen eine Prozessen beteiligt
sind
sie haben es gerade gesagt es gibt
diesen Vorschlag dass man verschleierte
Frauen in den Städten quasi platzieren
könnte damit es wieder mehr werden in
der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung und wie das
islamische Regime die Frauen gezwungen
hat sich zu bedecken das hat mein
Kollege Christian Volk kurz
zusammengefasst
Mitte des 20 Jahrhunderts unter dem
weltlichen share Regime bekommen die
Frauen in Iran mehr Rechte die
traditionelle Kleidung abgeschafft der
Schleier sogar verboten doch seit der
islamischen Revolution 1979 und dem
Sturz des Schahs ist damit Schluss
zehntausende Frauen aus allen
politischen Lagern protestieren gegen
den geplanten Kopftuch Zwang aber die
konservativ religiöse Führung ist
stärker mit den Jahren wächst der Unmut
in der Bevölkerung immer wieder gibt es
heftige Proteste gegen die strengen
Kleriker in den großen Metropolen sehen
viele Frauen die Bekleidungsregeln
mittlerweile eher locker die Regierung
versucht deshalb seit Monaten die
islamischen Gesetze wieder härter
auszulegen
ja es heißt ja jetzt dass das Regime
bereit wäre sich mit der Frage zu
beschäftigen ob und wie die Frauen in
Iran Kopftuch tragen müssen sich
bedecken müssen Frau tecker wie
realistisch ist das also die
Unterdrückung der Frau ist ja im Prinzip
eine der Säulen auf die die Mullahs ihre
Macht aufbauen und letztlich muss man ja
auch sagen es geht den Menschen ja um so
viel mehr als um das Kopftuch
ganz genau also wir dürfen sozusagen
nicht der Tatsache auch nein gehen zu
behaupten das wäre im Kopftuch Prozesse
das hatte ich sogar für hoch gefährlich
sondern es geht ja um so viel mehr es
geht um Grundrechte und das merken wir
eben auch daran dass die Frauen mit und
ohne tador dieser und Kopftuch sozusagen
für die Glaubensfreiheit ihrer
Schwestern auf den Straßen kämpfen
deswegen funktioniert das schon mal gar
nicht nichtsdestotrotz ist sozusagen
diese Ideologie auf diesen Kopftuch
aufgebaut und wird sozusagen politisch
missbraucht und diejenigen die sich
dagegen wehren sind in erster Linie die
Frauen selber sie machen den besten
Sinne was sie wollen und setzen damit
Stück für Stück haben die sozusagen
diesen Gesetzen was entgegengesetzt dass
das tödliche Folgen haben kann dürfen
wir nie vergessen wenn wir an den Beginn
dieser Revolution erinnern die ja
sozusagen
keine kein Einzelfall war sondern wo er
sozusagen der große breite Widerstand
eben auch gezeigt hat was für ein riesen
riesen gut Potenzial das eben auch hat
und die Frauen werden nicht aufhören das
ist auch der Grund warum insbesondere
meine Kollegin Gilda von Anfang an immer
wieder gesagt hat das was da passiert
ist eine feministische Revolution weil
sie auch von den Frauen angeführt ist
unter dem sozusagen auch unter der
Unterstützung auch der ganzen
Gesellschaft der Männer die das auch
beklatschen die alle selber Schwestern
Mütter Töchter haben und sagen das
wollen wir nicht mehr aber machen wir
uns keine Illusion ich kann mich dann
nur wiederholen wenn dieses Kopftuch
fällt fällt dieses Regime und
tatsächlich die Perfidität müssen wir
noch weiterentwickeln auf der einen
Seite geht es darum
sozusagen dazu zu zwingen das kommt doch
aufzusetzen wenn es aber nicht aufsetzen
dann sind sie uns endlich und dürfen
vergewaltigt werden wenn die Jungfrauen
sind sowieso und wir erfahren grausame
Nachrichten ich möchte noch mal die
Aufmerksamkeit denken auch auf die
Situation im Gefängnissen das Thema
Vergewaltigung als Kriegswaffe das was
wir dort hören er nicht erst seit dem
CNN Bericht ist das genau das passiert
dass die Frauen sich die Pille danach
wünschen dass die Wetter sagen wir
schicken euch eure Kinder schwanger
zurück wir haben mehrere selbstmordfälle
und das ist etwas was wir weiter
verfolgen weiter dokumentieren müssen
und ich möchte Bilder da nichts
vorwegnehmen aber sie hat das Beispiel
mit Shirin genannt die
Friedensnobelpreisträgerin die
beschrieben hat was das bedeutet hat als
aus ihr eine als eine Frau ein Objekt
geworden ist von 43 Jahren und sie haben
die Bilder gerade gezeigt also auch die
Bilder des Beginns dieser Revolution der
Duft der Geist ist immer noch da und
damit würde ich gerne auch überleiten an
meine Kollegin
Frau
also die sind natürlich alles gesagt
dazu also es ist ähm ich guckte auch
sehr oft auf deutsche Medien das war von
Anfang an eigentlich ein Problem dass
eben immer über dieses Kopftuch
gesprochen wurde sehr viel von der
Debatte wenn es um den Iran geht auch
schon vor Beginn dieser Protestbewegung
ging es immer um das Kopf hoch und ähm
das führt leider dazu dass gerade bei
uns dieses Kopftuch instrumentalisiert
wird von verschiedenen Seiten und das
lenkt natürlich total ab von dem was im
Iran los ist man kann die die
Zwangsverschleierung die Meran herrscht
und die haben vorher gesehen das sind
Frauen wie wir die wir hier sind und von
heute auf morgen von heute auf morgen
muss ich vorstellen ab morgen sind alle
unsere rechte Weg so mit einmal wir
müssen uns verschleiern wir dürfen keine
Haut zeigen öffentlich dürfen nicht mit
Männern durch die Straßen laufen wir
sind komplett in rechtet und das ist mit
den Menschen dort passiert von heute auf
morgen und deswegen
wenn man übrigens es wurde vor auch
gesagt es wurde auch
vorher unter der unter dem Schaf also
lange vorher zum Beispiel auch mal
Frauen verboten das Kopftuch zu tragen
auch das war schlecht also jede Art von
Zwang in Bezug auf Verschleierung ist
schlecht und im Iran herrscht nun mal
ein Zwang zu Verschleierung und dagegen
wehren sich die Frauen aber diese
Verschleierung dieses Kopftuch ist eben
nur ein Symbol für alles was diesen
Trecker gerade auch beschrieben hat die
Misshandlungen die Vergewaltigung und
die Folterungen all das was gerade
täglich stattfindet was seit 1979
stattfindet und Frauen nicht nur Frauen
Opposition insgesamt im Iran wird ja
auch sexualisiert das heißt jede Person
die sich Wert gegen den Staat ist Zitat
von Regine Prostituierte oder Promis so
benennen Sie das und deswegen dagegen
wären sich die Frauen und die Menschen
und es geht nur vordergründig und es
Kopftuch und da habe ich auch unbedingt
noch mal fort Mysterie erwähnen eine
unfassbar mutige Frau die die gläubig
ist die Verschleierung trägt freiwillig
weil sie es möchte weil sie weil es ihr
wichtig ist und die eine der mutigsten
Frauen ist in der Frauenbewegung schon
seit Jahren und daran sieht man wieder
es hat nichts mit dem Kopftuch per se zu
tun
am Ende geht es einfach darum die
Freiheit zu haben zu entscheiden wie man
leben möchte und trotzdem wie Frau
tickerl gesagt hat fällt das Kopftuch
fällt dieses Regime ich möchte gerne
noch mal ganz kurz auf diesen
Generalstreik zu sprechen kommen denn
gleichzeitig kommt ja auch von der
Justiz die Ankündigung dass
Todesurteile gegen Demonstranten jetzt
bald vollstreckt werden sollen ist das
so ein typisches Propaganda Instrument
das eben durch solche Ankündigungen der
Druck dann auch noch mal ganz massiv
erhöht wird Frau
ja das ist ja genau diese Widerspruch
den man jetzt in Bezug auf die
Sittenpolizei gezeigt hat also auf der
einen Seite wird dieser mediale
Versuchsballon gestartet mit die
Sittenpolizei abgeschafft auf der
anderen Seite haben wir Minderjährige
die gerade auf ihr Todesurteil warten
und die ist höchstwahrscheinlich auch
bekommen werden und Hinrichtungen die
gerade vollzogen wurden wobei das waren
jetzt keine Menschen die in diesem
Protesten verurteilt wurden sondern
schon davor dass es kein Stück besser
macht nur zeigt damit zeigt sieht man
und das zeigt dass dieses Regime immer
noch dieselbe in die exakt selber
Strategie fährt 44 Jahren auf der einen
Seite den Schein der legitimierten
Legitimität waren vor allem in Bezug auf
den Westen auf anderen Nationen und
innerhalb des Landes mit äußerster
verurteilt Grausamkeit und Gewalt Angst
und Schrecken verbreiten und das ist
gerade ihre Ihr System mal wieder es ist
wie gesagt nichts Neues aber jetzt sind
sie in die Ecke gedrängt und das heißt
dass diese diese Brutalität gerade nur
noch zunimmt
ich möchte noch zwei drei Kommentare
Vorlesen Soßenbinder schreibt die Frauen
dort tun mir echt leid echt traurig was
da abgeht MS 08 und ein paar Zahlen
folgen noch schreibvolle Solidarität mit
den Protestierenden
let's left to see schreibt die Proteste
dürfen erst stoppen wenn das Regime
gestürzt ist dann braucht das Land alle
Unterstützung die es kriegen kann und
Frau Tacker vielleicht die letzte Frage
an Sie selbst wenn die Molas in den
nächsten Wochen Monaten Zugeständnisse
machen sollten würden sich die Menschen
damit im Land zufrieden geben oder haben
sie das alles so satt dass sie außer
einem kompletten Regime wechseln nichts
anderes akzeptieren würden
die Menschen wollen den Regimewechsel
und genau dabei sollten wir Sie
unterstützen einschalten
damit danke ich Ihnen Frau sahibi Frau
tekkal vielen Dank dass Sie sich Zeit
genommen haben für ihre Erläuterung und
wünsche Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend
machen es gut tschüss vielen Dank
schönen
ja und auch Ihnen und Euch natürlich
vielen vielen Dank für die Fragen und
Kommentare ich hoffe wir konnten dann
doch einiges davon klären Tschüss bis
bald